[Music]
welcome to your very first podcast thank
you
we're rolling I'm so thank you for
having me this is a momentous occasion
for a number of reasons
I mean the first family member that I've
had on the podcast and I've been looking
forward to this for a very long time I
mean the occasion is of course this
remarkable achievement of writing this
incredible book the George Marshall the
defender of the Republic that's coming
out in July and we're going to talk
about that I mean lug this is this is a
serious book for serious people you know
it's like 600 I mean then it's like over
how long is this 604 page 604 without
the notes I'm intimidated I've just
started to read it and it's amazing it's
all explained take me it's gonna take me
a while to get through it but first of
all congratulations thank you it's no
small thing
and the early feedback on this book has
been quite spectacular
you have the Ryan holiday stamp of
approval he loves it and you have
incredible blurbs from only Walter
Isaacson and General Stanley McChrystal
it's been quite something right Petraeus
it looks like you're gonna do an event
with him perhaps yeah we're doing in New
York and next fall yeah Wow like the 90s
he'll do like an interview thing like
you're doing right I think 92nd Street
wise well now it's gonna be at the New
York historic which is yeah I know
different place yeah but he yeah he
likes he wants to do it so that's kinda
gratifying
so no I know I didn't ask him he just
sort of said let's do this so right but
you how do you how do you even like
reach out to those people various ways
yeah I mean it's quite widely how you've
done that with Petraeus I had a friend
who you know your your cousin's roommate
at West Point I heard about the book and
started we started corresponding an
email he was head of the Army in Europe
and just just just retired and he
contacted Pitts
and Petraeus got in touch with me yeah
and said you know I'm headed to the
Southeast Asia you know send me a
digital copy that book so yeah so the
third book I feel like this butter is
gonna really be the book that's gonna
break out hope so so I think so what
we're gonna talk about all of that but I
you know I have I have this opportunity
now to talk to you about a lot of things
that I've always wanted to talk to you
about uh I think the formality of this
kind of allows us to explore that a
little bit you know like questions that
you always have that you just never feel
like it's the right time to ask about
your life you know all right
and how you got to this place like you
know I think when I think back to to my
grandparents like Everett and Garnett
like my memory of them as is as of old
you know when they were old and I don't
fly ever really it feels like you know
in my memory of course is is you know
far from perfect so I remember them
being quite a bit older but I'm curious
about you know how you grew up and and
what kind of parents they were and and
kind of what kind of kid you were you
know when I think what I think back you
know for what it must have been like for
you as a young person I know at one
point you mentioned that there was there
was that movie that came out that
Terrence Malick movie that came out
called tree of life yeah that with Brad
Pitt and it was it was of that era and I
remember you saying to me like that's
that's what it was like when I was a kid
when they laid about in the safety he
stuck with me yeah so yeah I mean I had
a very you know uneventful but very
pleasant you know perfect childhood and
I I grew up in a suburb of Detroit
called ghost Point lived there until I
you know went away to college and my
parent my
father came off a farm farm town and in
middle Illinois very poor and I never
knew I never knew his parents in other
words that part of my grandparents I
didn't know there was a farm in Illinois
that we visited a couple times so he was
a guy that you know came through the
Depression and you know made his way to
the illah
you know University of Illinois where I
met my mother my mother was from a much
more middle-class family mm-hmm and they
met at the University of Illinois right
after the Red Grange era but they you
know they graduated right near the
depression actually on the cusp of it
the beginning of the depression so my
father was lucky to get a job in Detroit
as an accountant and that's what he
studied at Illinois and and worked for
the Detroit Edison Company we were up I
would say a middle class family and a
middle class upper middle class suburb
so we lived on a street with you know
lots of kids this was you know post-war
baby boom right she got ill everyone
yeah my house and have a car yeah they
all in and Detroit's a big car city so
we you know we knew every single car
that would come down and when a
Studebaker came that looked you know the
front you couldn't tell the front from
the back that was like the biggest thing
in our neighborhood so we put on a
carnival when we were kids and seven
eight nine ten years old for polio polio
was a big deal when we were growing up
so we had a friend they lived in the
next over the next block who died you
know of polio it's always a it was kind
of a threat and everybody thought it was
coming from the water you know in the
lake but a lake we would live right near
the Lake st. Clair so they closed all
the swimming I just received a call
three days ago from probably my oldest
friend
who I lived behind us across a field
name was Charlie Harris and you know he
was a he was a while while kid who loved
chemistry and he became a tenured
professor at Berkeley yeah and the head
of the department of acid Kempf
biophysics our biochemist biochemistry
very now he's very famous but he has
Parkinson's he just called me the other
day left me a voicemail for my birthday
Wow you know it was amazing Charlie
that's one of the things that I really
admire about how you've lived your life
is you stayed really close with these
friends that you've had your entire life
like it's not just Charlie you've got
like four or five of them that you visit
every year and you really are in contact
with in a way that that I don't have in
my life it's not my experience
well I'd my book you probably didn't
read the the dedication which is in the
first few pages of the book this is the
George Marshall book and I dedicated it
to Mike and Charlie you know and they
are two of my oldest not the Charlie
Harris who's the guy I knew when I was
four years old another Charlie and Mike
who I played football with in high
school and they are you know two of my
closest friends and we still see each
other and like next week I'm gonna go
have birthday dinner with them yeah and
Charlie went on to become a successful
Washington lawyer and Mike was a was a
frogman which is kind of the prototype
of the neat the Navy SEALs right yeah it
it was the the sort of the special ops
group that preceded the seals right I
turned into the seals so he he was in
Tootsie two trips to Vietnam yeah and
then hunting diamonds in Brazil so he's
like a stud you know yeah
and join us yeah well you know now he's
79 years old so so his chart charlie is
a
Charlie and I both kind of turned away
from the law when we were you know 15
years ago said we're not going to do
this anymore and so Charlie went to grad
school got a master's in English or yeah
so right now American history and then I
started writing books so right we kind
of went that way Charlie's an amazing
guy yep you know a true renaissance
connector a gentleman a very charismatic
individual all right all right
good friends so you grew up with these
guys you end up playing football in high
school
all right I mean it's it's an
all-american story anyways and yeah high
school you know girls I met your I met
your mother when she was 16 actually I
met her when we were in ninth grade but
when we run a trip out west together I
can get into later burger you know I met
so I've known I've known my my wife now
of mmm 50 plus years since high school
so that's like unusual yeah
well most of my friends parents are
divorced you know you guys have really
you know made it work over a long haul
like when you think back on how that
unfolded and how you continue to you
know work on your relationship and you
know keep the love alive like to what do
you attribute that oh I don't know it's
it's you know it's not it's not like it
was it's it's not like it's easy to have
a you know a smoother relationship over
that amount of time and of course it's
morphed it's changed it's but it's you
know it's pretty amazing it was pretty
amazing so you know how many years well
if we've got married in 1963 right that
you know while I was still in high
school so ever since then what it was it
it's a long time yeah it's getting there
yeah mid 50s
so actually about your age yeah
mm-hmm so that's and you know I my wife
is sitting not she's right off camera
over here so care now I mean we you know
when we were growing up the idea of a
divorce was scandalous and my mother my
mother was a real gossip and you know it
at at dinner table there would be all
kinds of disparaging remarks about
people who were either seeing
psychiatrists and there was one woman in
our neighborhood was seeing a
psychiatrist like a huge scandal always
my mother built it up to be you know a
sin and then you know divorce was just
and that and that happened to Mike might
one of the one of the two guys that this
the frogman guy in them in the midst of
high school it was front-page news paper
news so I remember him one morning came
over for a ride to school with my father
and myself and that was the day the
headlines came out his his his family
was somewhat is somewhat prominent in
the history of Detroit so they it was
like front-page and if his parents were
getting divorced and I made the
newspaper oh yeah why I think was in the
Detroit News yes like you know and Mike
felt you know it was Tara was a terrible
thing for him well that must have played
on your psyche over the years as an
impediment to divorce you know what you
don't stay married for that long without
having moments where it looks like it
might break so yeah and you don't you
know won't let that happen so yeah
exactly that's exactly right and I'm
sure it's you know without brich Arlie
and Mike have been married as long as as
I haven't Charlie Harris the other the
other guy I think the berkeley professor
you know has been devoured divorced
three times so yeah well to be clear
though you know i don't want anyone to
get the impression that you're you're in
it just because like you thought you've
said to me many times even over the last
year like you know i'm really
love with your mom yeah you know and
that's no small thing no that's right
you know and she's in love with me yeah
was Everett a taskmaster or what kind of
dad was ever it was I think he was
laconic in a way he was he didn't say a
lot part of it was my mother my mother
was the gregarious social person and he
was much more much quieter but you know
he had a commanding in a way about him
part of it though is just due to the
fact that he had a hearing defect and
you know it so it it it hindered him in
sort of socialization like laconic in
the sense of being emotionally
disconnected and not not really yeah you
know but when he said stuff or
criticized me which is rarely rare but
you did you know that was like oh my god
what if I you know I've you know right
losing his respect so you know and I had
a very extraordinary older brother much
older than I was eight or nine years so
and he was you know he was as we were
growing up you know he was like mr. big
in terms of having a I think they even
they used to take us in hip we had our
IQs you know done so I his IQ was like
and everybody knew what everyone's ID
you score was academic you know yeah
he's up a prodigious academic he's a
nuclear physicist and a in a
extraordinary French horn player so you
know it but you know sort of had real
problems with social social skills but
anyway so he was always the you know the
the the person that you know that I had
to live up to in some ways
intellectually but I was never you know
in his League I don't think is that
making resentful no the one thing it did
was I said I'm not going to the same
college he went to and you know I could
have gone where he went and decided to
go to a you know where I could you know
Excel let you know nada I wanted to play
football you know so I went to go to a
divisions division through it didn't
back then it wasn't that way but it was
a small school yeah where´s college
right well what you know one of the
things that I think we share is you know
we're both we're both competitive and
we're both ambitious driven yeah very
driven and I feel I feel like you had
this sense that you wanted to you know
get out of Detroit and make a name for
yourself and do something different on
your own terms
well except I didn't get out of Detroit
at first you know what I what I really
wanted to do is get out of law school
fast and start making money and see you
know whether I can make a name in the
legal profession but you know and I
didn't hit I went into the law school
without a lot of circumspection about I
got to be a lawyer that was always what
I wanted to do our always wanted to go
into court or something like that and
you know it was a good profession you
could you could you know make a living
at it
and it was a big deal to have a job you
know getting out of college and my
parents you know that was a huge thing
with them was yeah you got to get a job
right you know so so so after Amherst I
mean you fast-tracked your law school
experience right didn't you start in the
summertime started the day after I
graduated from college literally we
drove all night I remember from Amherst
to to Ann Arbor Michigan and they
dropped me off at the law school at 8:00
in the morning you know and I had an 8
o'clock class up on his first class in
law school and that's where I met the
famous kurt lidtke that's right
standing outside the door of our
classroom smoking cigarettes it's a
classic story so for those that are
listening Kurt lucky is kind of a
notorious famous character who
was your roommate for a period of time
and ended out late he became a
journalist and then became a
screenwriter in a second act of his
career kind of famously announced I'm
gonna be a screenwriter now and
everybody laughed and his first his
first screenplay was called absence of
malice that ended up getting directed by
Sydney [ __ ] starring Paul Newman and
Sally Field in his second square was
nominated for that one nominee for Best
Original Screenplay Oscar nomination
his second screenplay was out of Africa
right and the third one was a bust what
yeah random hearts kind of never came
back from that well he just didn't want
to do it yeah he also never he refused
to go to Los Angeles recalls everybody
in Los Angeles scum
I think he like made Sydney [ __ ] come
to Michigan to meet with him that's
right I mean city you know Sydney
[ __ ] like a legend of you know
Hollywood filmmaking right at the time
but at that time when you met him he was
kind of a carousing notorious character
all right we had in law school we there
were three of us four of us actually
living in us you know in the law quad as
they called it and but Kurt he never he
never went to class except if the class
was in the mid to late afternoon he
would go otherwise he didn't go to any
classes right wasn't he dating like a
nurse yeah she didn't get off until
midnight so it was kind of a difficult
yeah you know I had to kind of get out
of there to study mmm but anyway we had
we had a good time right and and so you
you then end up getting a job at a law
firm in in Detroit back to Grosse Pointe
you meet my well you reconnect with mom
because she was I went to grad at
Michigan when Laura started law school
she was still you know in her senior
year and then the this the second summer
I took off rather than stay in law
school and we got married that summer
1963 uh-huh
and and then we lived in a little
apartment near the stadium the
University of Michigan
for my final year and Nan and my wife
Nancy was studied speech and hearing and
got a job right away as it you know in a
local school so we finished that out
then I got a job started working in
Detroit we lived in Detroit for a couple
years and then moved into crosspoint
where I grew up and that's when I
started thinking about going somewhere
else yeah well a couple things first of
all over the years you you you always
had a knack for having like an iconic
car like you had a Dodge Dart and then
we had a we had a VW Beetle and then I
remember you had that like Navy that
that like midnight blue Navy mustang
mustang that was a beautiful car yeah
nineteen what is it 1964 flat 65 I think
it was I think they came out in 64 we
got one in 65 yeah and there's a great
photo of you in your diapers you know
when you're two or one-and-a-half
helping me wash that Mustang I know that
oh and you know that was a big deal I
think for you I think more of it more
for me well I look at that photo and I'm
like oh man if you'd only hung on to
that car but the first car I had that
when I went to a more she weren't
supposed to have cars immersed is in
Amherst Massachusetts a small all men's
college so I had my mother didn't
realize what she was doing but she let
me have her English anglia this was the
worst English price it was an English
Ford and I don't know why she bought it
was the cheapest car you could possibly
buy in the United States I think and it
was like almost made out of cardboard
I've never even heard of that yeah well
I had it at Amherst secretly you're
north and you know parked in town
somewhere so I could use it and actually
when Nancy came to visit me for you know
the annual big weekend and she came with
an another
[Music]
another young lady from Grosse Pointe
who was dating my you know one of my
best friends they came to Amber's for
the weekend and while we were in that
english anglia we got arrested what
happened
I forgot exactly how it happened we were
I guess I were speeding or something and
we ended up in the Amherst Police
Department headquarters this little
Police Department and they know because
I was because I was supposed to have a
car and you know I was an Amherst
student it was actually against the law
well was against the regulations of the
other of the college and I had to go
before uh before a court a court of on
an honor court hmm at Amherst and I
don't know it was suspended Judah Kate
this transgression oh yeah driving a car
without permission of the car and then I
think you could have a car when you were
senior but anyway we'd used to drive
that that the car back and forth from
Amherst to to Michigan it was you know
an adventure because it would it would
constantly break down it right and so
forth we didn't have enough money to go
on the Turnpike so we drive the back
roads in English Anglia all the way
uh-huh between break down country
tonight my next cornfield I can't
imagine anybody interested I am well I I
mean so when is the you know when is
this idea of like moving to to
Washington and are your consciousness I
mean was there a sense like this is
where the action is like I want to be
involved in in you know this is where
things are happening and important
people are making important decisions
and this was Nixon when the early Nixon
and actually there was a lot of reform
going on in Washington of course it was
preceded by Kennedy's ask what you can
you know I do and so forth but I was I I
wanted to be a big-time antitrust lawyer
which means you know litigating against
corporations on you know economic issues
and breaking up
breaking up big business that kind of
thing I was really entranced with the
idea of you know there's too much
monopoly power and you know in the
American economy and it was it was a you
know it was an exciting field and I
couldn't get enough of it at the law
firm I was with in Michigan and then
this book came along who now this one of
my really good friends a book called the
first first expose of the big law firms
in Washington and it was called the
super lawyers so it was about a bunch of
the guys at at the big law firms and
they weren't big then but the major law
firms in Washington and it was about
what they did they did huge kinds of
interesting pro bono work you know they
were arguing Supreme Court cases they
were breaking up companies or defending
the companies it was written by a guy
named Joe Gould --an and Joe golden now
is in his 90s but he's one of my really
good friends and he's been mentoring me
on writing books ever since I started I
never knew that and he just lives like
two blocks away so he's you know been my
big fan you know I wrote an op-ed piece
a few weeks ago about NATO and I wanted
to get it published you know in a decent
newspaper you know you send it to the
times of the post and they don't know
who you are
yeah but he helped me get it published
not in the greatest newspaper of all but
it was the Washington Times it's the
first time I got an op-ed piece and you
know he he made it happen anyway so then
I had a really good friend from Amherst
who was working in Washington and he
called me one day and said if you ever
want to come to Washington call this guy
so I bottled in no this was a different
guy yeah a friend of mine that I went to
Amherst with who was working in the
Justice Department he said if you ever
wanna do antitrust in Washington call
this guy so I called a guy and he was at
FTC guy you know recruiting lawyers and
at the time Ralph Nader nobody was
listening to this would probably ever
heard of Ralph in a birthday I mean he
you know Fame
perhaps most famous for the Pinto thing
yeah right but Ralph Nader had had this
group of hotshot young lawyers that were
called ray Nader's Raiders and they went
into the FTC the Federal Trade
Commission and they identified all kinds
of scandals and corruption and so forth
the FTC pre Nixon was you know filled
with a lot of Southern guys that were
just kind of living off the land and
they so they and as a result they had a
lot of investigations they cleaned house
they brought in a really respected
chairman of the FTC miles Kirkpatrick
from Philadelphia and he was staffing
the FTC with all these young hotshots
and I wanted to be a young hotshot so I
got a great job there I just I was just
very lucky and I was head I headed up
you know a quarter of the antitrust
cases that they were doing I had 28
suddenly I had I was 32 years old I had
20 28 or 29 30 lawyers working for me
and we were investigating the oil
industry it was like heaven you know or
that we we went after Xerox at the time
which had 99 percent of the market and
in popping so you know we were and we
had economists and we went around and
there was like a new energy in that
organization to really like affect
change and way it was the best job I
ever had
and we I probably should have stayed in
longer but stayed in for three years and
there was a lot of Esprit it was we
versus them the best lawyers in
Washington were always on the other side
so we were the young guys that were
trying to break her on we probably
wasted a lot of taxpayer I'm sure we've
wasted a lot of taxpayer money on her
cases but we you know we we we sit we
sued the oil industry which are the big
eight companies under a new you know
shared monopoly kind of theory so it was
lots of fun how long were you at the FTC
about three years three years I thought
it was longer than that no so now
seventy so I was out I was went in it's
the 1972 came
about three years later and I and I
thought I always thought I'd go back to
my law firm in Detroit because I was a
partner in that law firm mm-hmm and you
know they wanted me to come back and so
forth but I decided to interview so with
law firms from the FTC you had to be
careful ethically about starting the
interview process but the big law firms
were looking for people you know coming
out of the FTC and coming out of the
Justice Department and to defend the
companies are being sued by all these
gay right so I interviewed actually came
close to working for Siddeley in Austin
which was the Chicago based firm that
was handling all the ATT after I left at
about the time I left the 8th the FTC
they were going after 8 the whole AT&T
telephone system and breaking it up so
Siddeley in Austin was defending all
those companies and they wanted you know
people like me so I went to Chicago we
interviewed them and then I got a I also
was interviewed by the firm I ended up
with going to was Steptoe and Johnson
because I had met the head of the
antitrust practices Steptoe when I was
in the FTC he was on the other side of a
case so ultimately this presents a
scenario in which you're jumping the
fence and changing sides right today was
there any kind of ethical dilemma around
that didn't cause me a lot of problems
yeah it then you know this was a very
prestigious law firm in Washington they
were bringing me in as a partner you
know if I'd gone in that firm as an
associate I don't know whether it would
have made partner I didn't go to Harvard
or Yale Law School which is where most
of them came from Harvard Yale Stanford
yeah so Michigan was you know it was a
top-ranked law school but it wasn't in
the you know in the higher right so this
was your entree or opportunity to kind
of come in with the big boys see if I
could swim in that in that atmosphere
and how old were you so like 35 I was -
no I was 35 yes but a part that was one
of about the age when you became partner
at that point right
but I had to prove myself when I got in
there so and so I think I was six or
something when we moved to Washington so
I must have been ten or something like
that when you join step toe yes yeah
yeah yeah or nine right yeah I'm at nine
or ten right yeah and yeah yeah you were
thrown into the you know to the
Washington Sea
so to speak and getting beat up on the
street corner while you were waiting for
the bus yeah I had a well documented I
mean you know I'm interested in in but
in and how you remember me at that
period of time like I just remember
myself being kind of a sensitive kid who
was a little bit awkward and
uncomfortable in my own skin and sort of
kind of bumbling around a little bit
confused like I was a sweet kid I was a
little introverted and you know kind of
had difficulty making friends unless I
was in like you know an optimal social
environment well yeah but you had you
know your best friend was Eric Melanie
that right right behind us we had a
neighborhood yeah I was there you get
you know you ride your bikes around the
neighborhood and all that kind of good
stuff
yeah and you know you went to the
Bethesda elementary school it seemed
like you were doing pretty well I but I
know you were somewhat awkward I think
it Bethesda elementary I didn't really
know what was going on and then I don't
think I was off to an excellent academic
start but perhaps around the time that
you joined step toe so you know suddenly
we went from you know very much middle
class to you then you know having you
know making a much better living yeah
and then you were able to send me to st.
Patrick's and that was like an
incredible environment in which I
thrived right and I kind of you know
came out of my skin at that period of
time I can't remember how you got to st.
Patrick's I don't I have no boss or NIT
your mother told me it wasn't close to
home I think there was I think you drove
me or took me to it but I think there
was a bus stop there was one of those
like it one of the circles Westmoreland
Circle or something like that where you
would drop me off and I take a bus but I
remember when you
waiting for the bus was it yeah well you
were waiting for the bus and there was
that guy that that used to you know make
your life miserable oh well that was a
Bethesda Elementary I think taking my
hat and all that stuff yeah there was a
lot worried about you know there was
this tough kid in the neighborhood you
know that was mmm harassing you but we
were you know I think it was from my
perspective I'd you know I didn't think
you were you know having a kid there's
certainly not having academic problems
or you know learning or anything like
that you were a smart smart kid you like
to read you you know you were picking up
on everything you know I we we we played
around with sports because I was you
know interested in that you know in
soccer that didn't seem to go so well
yeah I mean I played soccer for a number
of years but I was absolutely you know
hopeless but of course you know the
minute you hit the water that was like
you know that was where you belonged and
uh and I think you know and you were
incentivized by just getting a trophy
you know yeah I mean there's nothing
like you know success - you know inspire
a young person I mean I was naturally
good at it and then of course you
gravitate towards you know what you're
you're you know sort of getting
accolades and and I was naturally good
at it although I think you know I don't
know i mean i think i was on a swim team
when I was like seven know something I
didn't it wasn't until like I was ten
and then I started getting good getting
serious yeah and then it became like
kind of really serious but you know I
remember those st. Patrick years like in
elementary school very fondly and then I
went off to landon and that became a
whole different story
ya know I'm sorry about that there's
nothing to apologize I'm een I remember
being very excited to get into that
school I mean it was like this
prestigious prep school and you had to
apply and you know it was a big deal you
know and I wanted to do well but I you
know in retrospect looking back like I
don't think it was the right environment
for me well I'd say Patrick's those are
the one there well as I said you should
go there is did they say that yeah
said well you know we don't think you
should go to st. Albans because I don't
know what because - and and Sidwell
doesn't give you enough structure you
know and they were the ones I think that
sort of directed you there and so it's
their fault I think they had a lot of
that but anyway if it was in and it was
not far away and it was it you know and
and I felt for you on some of those
situations I mean looking back on it
I've made I've really made peace with a
lot of it I think I held on to a
resentment about it for a long time and
you know I've exerted a lot of energy to
kind of work through all of that and I
would say that reconnecting with Tom
Scott and then participating in the
Nantucket project last year and seeing a
bunch of people from my class who also
attended that was incredibly healing and
has given me kind of a revisionist
perspective on it that's allowed me to
feel a lot better about it and the truth
is like look these are you know 1% or
you know problems like I had the
privilege of growing up in a family
where you guys could provide everything
that I needed and you know send me to
these these amazing academic
institutions that gave me an incredible
you know head start but I think I think
one advantage of it that you you know
you're you you have real you know that
you had they came out of it some it a
real you know a look your life was not
that tough no I in you know in in almost
all respects but you know the one thing
that they said was you know you can't
you know swim with this club team
because you're gonna miss mandatory
football in this in the fall or baseball
or lacrosse in the spring and they had
this very rigid sports program at at
landing and you can't miss that whereas
if you want to be a top swimmer you got
to work out
in the morning and then you got a
workout in the afternoon and it's you
know you just have to do that and you
took it upon yourself to go to the
administration and make your case and
say look I have to do this and if I
can't you know if he won't let me I'm
gonna have to leave the school mm-hmm
big threat yeah they were quaking and
over that no they won't eat him but they
but you were doing it well academically
very well academically and they didn't
want to lose you you know you were gonna
be one of the kids that's going to get
into Harvard or you know Stanford or
whatever swimming or not so you know and
they had they respected somebody who's
come and make his case I think you did
it in writing well I haven't i had an
ally in the headmaster well Meltzer
Codes who who actually you know liked me
and was a fan and was a support system
for me the athletic department was not
you know looking upon that as kindly and
who was a coach again that well it was
lolled a little yes like director and he
just had it in him that he was gonna
defeat me no matter what and I'm like
this little skinny fifteen-year-old kid
who's just saying like I want to go swim
with this club team swim in the morning
swim in the afternoon I don't want to do
sports Atlanta and I'm not gonna like I
remember the headmaster saying well what
happens later in life when you know you
you go to the club and you're gonna play
tennis and I just thought well that's
not my life I'm not gonna be that's not
the guy that I'm gonna be I want to do
I really am committed to trying to be
excellent in this regard and confounded
me and confused me and angered me that
they couldn't see that and wouldn't
support that and so I really did like I
put it in writing and you help me like
you helped me make a case like we had to
litigate this and there's not an
overnight thing at first they said no
and it went through all these iterations
until finally they relented and I think
if I'm if I'm correct that at least at
that time I was the only person they had
ever exempted from their athletic
department to allow me to go do this
thing which I then did
and they're gonna they said if this kid
gets away with it what's yeah like
what's the precedent it's this next game
you guys what every slope argument and
then I think junior year is when I
wanted to participate in the high school
the local high school Swimming
Championships metros and in order to do
that your high school had to have a swim
team and my high school did not have a
swim team so I started one it was there
was one member I would say wasn't wasn't
there one other guy I don't I don't
think so but I had to piggyback on these
other high school meets in order to like
go through the ramifications of
qualifying and then ended up you know
doing well at that meet and to this day
there is a swim team at landed now and I
feel like I helped birth that in my own
right you know kind of in elegant way
but that was quite a saga and I will say
you know also you know I have to thank
you for supporting me in pursuing that
dream because it was you know it was
like an off center thing and it required
you waking up with me at Rousey every
morning and surviving me to swim
practice secretly hoping you wouldn't
and you did that you had the little mg
and you would drive me as from practice
and you would sit in the car while I was
training in the dark cold and like mark
up these briefs like work in the car
until I was done and you did that until
I could get a driver's license and that
was a huge thing and I think about that
all the time I think about that when you
know now we're in the this this
situation where you know our home is
fractured and Julie and I are living in
two different places during the week and
you know we're trying to support Mathis
in art school and it's not easy and I
think I caught up and drove me to some
practice at 4:30 in the morning like
this is the least I can do to pay it
forward for my own child but the good
thing is you don't have to go to swim
meets every stairs yeah that's that's
the harder part right oh yeah yeah
driving out to Bowie and sitting in a
steamy chlorinated natatorium fires 2
hours I usually actually take boxes of
docket this in the days you know way
before computers when it when we did all
our antitrust cases with documents and
it
a box of documents to the swimming meet
I could finish a whole box during the
during a swim you mean because people
who aren't used to that don't realize it
but their child only has about you know
two minutes of glory and during an
entire date hours you know draw and
driving to these you know places way out
in the middle of nowhere but you did
that we Wow yeah and we became kind of
you know pent up the kind of parents
that you know that are aggressively you
know involved with not like we were
screaming at anybody or anything like
that but we were we were pushing it you
know and we wanted you to succeed and we
knew how happy it made you and of course
not just you but our daughter as well
mm-hmm so I felt that I mean you you
were never like the you know the the
crazy parents on the you know in the
stands yelling or anything like that but
there was definitely a sense if not an
expectation that you will succeed yeah
you know and I felt that in my shoulder
that and I was able to fulfill that I
think in certain respects but I also
think I paid you know I paid a toll for
that as well yeah well it I think it it
it also exempted you from some of the
knocks the knocks that you would might
otherwise receive going through high
school you know like you know you got it
maybe get a part-time job maybe learn
more about girls maybe learn more about
social stuff maybe get into a little
trouble
mm-hmm you know with alcohol or whatever
but earlier yes and learn you know not
being exposed to and landing of course
is you know there was a social scene at
land and that you weren't in no I not
only did I accept myself from the
athletic program I exempted myself from
the social environment right and so me
and I lived a very monk-like existence I
would wake up ridiculously early I'd go
to some practice I you know get through
school I whenever
was a study hall I would fall asleep on
a desk I was exhausted all the time and
would go to swim practice after school
and then do my homework and be asleep by
nine o'clock every day and there was and
then weekends were swim meets right yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the kids Atlanta knew
it knew they knew that that's that's
what you were doing so you know the
Proms
I didn't trouble like didn't do any of
that normal stuff and so you had to face
up to it but I was but I was very driven
I was like I'm gonna get into all these
schools and I got into all of them and
you know that was like you know I mean
12 for 12 it was a pretty epic to get
into like basically every college you
apply to you know and I think you know
there was a you know I obviously that's
gonna make you feel good but I'd also I
felt I felt like the weight of that too
I think like what does that mean and
like what is how does that impact like
the choices you're gonna make later in
life with what you're gonna do with
yourself I thought an interesting thing
you know that I always thought you and
Neal Phillips would go off to Harvard
and yeah talk about Neal Phillips and
and how he was regarded at length on how
you were and how you became together
sure so Neal Phillips was the best
athlete in our school and Landon school
was a boys prep school it was small and
exclusive there were only like 60 people
in my class Neal was african-american a
very gifted athlete an incredible an
incredibly charismatic individual and
intelligent the best basketball player
the best football player he played he
played all three sports baseball gets
into Harvard I mean just you know on
this incredible trajectory toward
success and he has blazed quite an
amazing path for himself he is now
regarded as a great civil rights leader
on behalf of you know he's championing
underprivileged african-american boys
and he now found it and runs this school
in Florida
and travels a lot is an incredibly
prolific public speaker the at the
Nantucket project this past fall he
interviewed george w bush on stage and
it was riveting
it was absolutely riveting to see two
people from very different perspectives
come together for you know compelling
talk was something to behold
and you know he's marched with john
lewis and he's done a lot of amazing
things and i have so much respect for
you know what he's done with his life
and you know to be able to reconnect
with him this past fall but you
connected with him back then didn't you
when when you both got into work yeah I
got into Harvard yeah I'm not going and
there listen there's plenty of times
where I think you know maybe I made a
mistake you know but I know that you
would have preferred me to go there and
look for a good reason you know who says
no to that like Who am I to decline that
opportunity that nobody gets you know
and how would my life have been
different you know it's hard to say it's
hard to say and I can't spend a lot of
time you know entertaining that but but
it definitely would have been different
I think but I was happy you know at
Stanford and that's when I started you
know making all of these mistakes and
kind of sowing some Wild Oats that I
never did in high school right and you
know I same thing would have happened at
Harvard but I think a lot of it is a it
was the expression of you know repressed
emotions that I didn't understand and
really didn't know how to process about
like what I was doing and like what
makes me happy I was on this path
towards success and upward mobility
without ever taking a moment to stop and
say well like what am I like what do I
want to do what do I want to be what it
what makes me happy because I I do think
that I was an offbeat kid and I think I
you know had I not had I not gotten into
any colleges I would have done some kind
of you know offbeat artistic thing you
know but I was on this path towards
being a consultant or an investment
banker or a lawyer or a doctor
then you know alcohol entered the
equation and then all bets were off you
know and hence you know assured in a
very painful period you know not just
for me but for you I mean what I put you
guys through I you know that was painful
yeah um talk about for a second I'm
interviewing you know I mean about
Michigan because Michigan was always on
the horizon because of your grandfather
and you went there and is that the first
time you started drinking I think I mean
I don't know that it would I it's the
first I'm gonna put on my Michigan ahead
put your Michigan hat on I went on I
went on a recruiting trip to the
University of Michigan I was I was
recruited there by the great John herb
and Shaq who was the coach at the time
still like my favorite swim coach ever I
think I just think he's the best and he
was really rebuilding the program at
that period of time and trying to create
something you know noteworthy and
remarkable with that he got that guy
other guy younger than you that made the
Olympics right from from Washington yeah
Tom Dolan no no well other Michael
Phelps no before that there was a guy
that did the canoeing Oh Mike barrel man
Behrman but I got a medal yeah yeah Mike
barrel man famous Olympic swimmer and
you know for those that didn't read my
book or are kind of coming into this you
know green I forgot it's in your book
right yeah but I mean a lot of people
who listen as I read the book my mother
who's sitting right over here her father
was a champion swimmer at the University
of Michigan in the late 1920s and early
1930s I believe he was captain of the
team in nursery 129 an Olympic hopeful
tried out for the Olympics in 32 in 32
and he got third or fourth whatever the
the one I think they were taking three
at the time and he got fourth so he
missed by one slot if I'm mistaken he
actually held the American record in the
150 yard backstroke which is no bet they
don't do it more
I mean you held an American record it's
really quite amazing and when you visit
the University of Michigan natatorium
it's called the map man auditorium that
was his coach I'm legendary swim coach
and along the hallways they have all of
the old team photos and you can find his
photo on the wall and now it's hanging
in my container office there's a picture
in the book and I never had the
opportunity to meet him because he
passed away before I was born he died of
a heart attack at age 54 and I know that
that was you know a very traumatic
experience and in my mother's life and
Nancy's life and I never really thought
that much about him I mean I would hear
stories about him but I didn't really
connect with his legacy emotionally
until you know I went on the zone you
know my own journey with alcohol and
then you know later on the second bottom
of like you know reconfiguring my
lifestyle that I started thinking about
him a lot more and now at 52 I think
about him all the time as I'm two years
shy of when he passed away and in so
many ways I feel this kinship with this
person that I've never met and so
certainly that was part of the allure of
you know attending Michigan and I
thought you know long and hard about
about doing that but get back to your
question yeah I went on a recruiting
trip to Michigan and there was a swim
meet going on during that visit and then
after the meet there was a there was a
big party and I remember being in
somebody's apartment and there was a keg
party and you know everybody's drinking
and I think maybe I'd had a beer too it
wasn't like my first beer ever running
like that but this was the first time
that I was in like an environment where
I really wanted to be part of this
social community you know I really like
looked up to all of these athletes and
there was one moment in particular where
there was the diver Bruce Kimball Oh
Bruce Kimmel was who was the most famous
diver in the world other
Greg Louganis at the time right Olympic
medalist his father dick Kimble was the
diving coach right
and Bruce Kimble they were from Ann
Arbor yeah right Bruce Kimble
Bruce Kimble you know had a beer in his
hand and he did the most amazing thing
that I've ever seen to this day where he
did he was holding his cake cup of beer
and from a flat foot he did a he did a
he jumped up in the air and did a
backflip and landed on his feet holding
this cup of beer and he didn't spill any
of it and I thought that is the most
amazing thing I've ever seen whatever
that guy has like I want it and I was
like I'm in let me have a beer you know
and I got loaded that night and ended up
partying with him of course you know the
sort of PostScript to that story is
Bruce Kimball would later
Carine his car into a crowd of people
killing oh I know at least one person
and going to jail you know he's he's an
alcoholic destroyed his life destroyed
his career you know when I say like I
want what that guy has like I did you
know and then I ended up going on you
know a less tragic version of that
trajectory in a way that I couldn't have
foreseen you think our band check knew
what was going on with the team when you
were recruiting no I mean listen you
know I think all of these coaches
whether they're swim coaches or you know
football coach they know they know these
kids are partying but you know they cast
a little bit of a blind eye they have to
keep a loose grip on this like they have
to let these kids you know do what
they're gonna do in college they can't
over police it so I think on some level
they kind of know and they make a choice
to not get too involved and I don't know
what it's like now but you know it was a
free-for-all when when I was in school
do you think skip knew yeah it's the
same thing you know I think he kind of
knew and kind of decided to you know not
make too big of a deal you guys weren't
joint
mainly drinking right it was drinking
yeah I never I never saw I mean once in
a while you'd see some kid doing hard
drugs in college but it wasn't part of
my experience you know it was just a
very it was a drinking culture and at
that time at Stanford I mean you could
roll a keg into the stands and just you
know have at it and go crazy I mean they
they don't let you do that anymore it
was the same when I was you know it was
you know whatever you wanted to do was
fine and it was just bananas and I went
crazy I think I you know coming from a
very structured environment to having
that kind of freedom I was ill-prepared
for that and I wasn't mature enough to
handle it and I just went full on but I
think there was a you know something
tweaked inside of me because my
relationship with alcohol was just
different from everybody else and I had
a if not a conscious awareness a
semi-conscious awareness of that from
the very beginning it just would take a
very long time but I would do anything
about it and you know just progressed
over time until I got you know really
dark and and terrible you know and I put
you guys through a huge amount of pain
every time I crosshair really sorry
every time I cross Pico Avenue coming
from the airport I think about you used
to live up there yeah well I lived on I
lived on marine off Main Street and
there was that time when you came and
visited me where I was really at my
nadir and it was after you know the
wedding that went awry and all of that
and it was a super dark moment where I
was like drinking in them was a rose
rose rose went to the Rose Bowl that's
the last time Michigan yet I can't even
think about that weekend without getting
really upset yeah I think it was really
you know it was hard not because not
because of the pain that I was in but
because of how I conducted myself with
you you know but I think ultimately that
that precipitated you know the solution
because that was after that visit you
were like I'm done like you you're
you're you're kind of on your own you
know we know what's going on and if you
want help we're here from you but you
know we don't we we can't really you
know participate in this end
more well we help you get some help yeah
you know it was you know but I'll never
forget that because it was the partly
because of Michigan it was the Michigan
National Championship game they ended up
sharing it with Nebraska but but it was
Woodson and and so actually had a pretty
good time that take yeah because you got
me out of the field I was standing in
the end zone what you know during the
third quarter that yeah but anyway you
know I wanted to you know just publicly
acknowledge that you know the support
that you showed me during those
difficult times like really allowed me
to get the help that I needed and to
change my life and you know it was just
it was a really hard time all of us very
very hard for us Nancy and and myself
yeah we because we had we had never
experienced you know a problem in our
family like that we had death you know
Nancy's father death that was and you
know but well then her brother and her
brother too on yeah top of it but you
know but sort of a you know a a
breakdown you know and in the family
dynamic was was very very difficult
before for us to deal with and we didn't
know how to deal with it and we didn't
want to talk about it a lot you know
with other people you know here was our
son you know really in trouble with
alcohol seeing fortunately seeing a guy
that you know got you in due to the
rehab mm-hmm which and then we all
travel to that and that was like an
amazing eye-opener for me and Nancy and
Molly who your nurse your sister family
week when I was chairman of the law firm
at the time and and you know part of the
you know part of the reason I stopped
doing it as long as I could have
was that I you know this whole thing you
know upset my life a lot no in the not
in the sense that I you know I wanted to
quit law or you know anything like that
but it was just like hey you know
there's more out there and there are the
things I can do then just you know
keeping my head down and doing my 3,000
hours a year or you know and you know
trying to run the law firm so it was it
was time for it was a you know it
actually was for me personally in the
end it was a positive thing to go to
have gone through that so I don't feel
you know and I felt you know you think
about what a lot more about life so part
of me I was also regrets the call I made
you know I sort of triggered this whole
thing in a way in terms of your path
because I remember when you were on the
waiting list at Cornell Law School and I
think the waiting list somewhere else
Georgetown or something yeah and I and
you were spending the summer in New York
and got onto a a movie project where you
were helping out with a production of a
movie and I called you up it was almost
Labor Day and said you know if you want
to go to law school and I'm not
suggesting that you should or shouldn't
but you're gonna have to get your stuff
together and be there in three days yeah
if you want to go and you know that was
sort of like you know what if that
didn't happen well that was one of those
pivotal moments I mean I was you know I
had been a legal assistant at a big law
firm in New York City and that kind of
ended and I'd applied to law school I
got rejected everywhere I was on the
waiting list at these two schools and in
the meantime I was a production
assistant on this low-budget independent
movie which I was out abortion right it
was called it was called rain without
thunder
nobody saw it but I actually that was
like the greatest job ever and my job
was to drive the talent around so I got
to pick up Jeff Daniels from the hosts I
don't know that and drive him to set and
I got to ask him all these questions
about working with you know this
director and that director and the
theatre company that he had in Michigan
who else like Steve Zahn was in that
movie Linda hunt remember from The
Killing Fields a really short woman she
won an Oscar for that I got to drive her
I mean it was you know I was getting
coffee it was a you know like lo on the
wrong job but it was really fun
but I was not in a good way and yeah I
didn't even have an apartment anymore I
was like couch surfing at friends so you
didn't even know how to get a hold of me
right but I had to be there right away
and I literally you know when I when
somehow you got in touch with a friend
of mine who my friend Chris Hildebrand
knows the guy was a Thai Brown yeah and
then I had to get you know from I had to
like pack my bag and go down to DC and
get a car and figure out where ethica
was and drive in there and like
literally I was in a loft a law school
class like the next day I didn't even
have an apartment I didn't know that I
was going at that point I had written
off that that was even going to be the
path for me
Pablo was there though um not at that
time because he had started there and
then he had stopped out to train for the
92 Olympics in Barcelona he then
finished when I finished so where did
our final year together but I think
about that too like what would happen
have that not happened but I don't think
me freewheeling it in New York City what
it ended well I think in certain
respects like getting me out of
Manhattan and into Ithaca in a
structured environment was probably a
good thing and I you know I actually
enjoyed Law School ultimately really
being uh being a lawyer in a law firm
was not the path for me but the academic
aspect of being in law school I actually
you know I have fun I've never heard you
say that you have it but I didn't like
Law School but I enjoyed it but yeah I
mean that could have been I mean you
know life
have been very very different that not
happened but you know here we are and
you know and and I think you know I
think it's also even in even in sobriety
for me it's been it's been a challenge
for you to see me make choices that are
kind of a little bit you know far afield
from what
perhaps you imagine it's not Georgetown
you see yeah so it's like I'm not you
know I didn't move back to Washington
I'm not driving a Volvo around with
stickers on the back window at the
schools that my kids go to like I chose
a different path and I think that's been
you know a process for you and mom too
you know acclimate to well yeah sure I
think we're okay now that weren't
showing up at the wedding and my journey
showing up at the wedding when you got
married to Julie within my sir Sakura
suit right
and with bhagavad ah standing seven feet
tall and sandalwood on his forehead yeah
you know I know it's a lot Julie was she
was she was seven months pregnant was
pregnant and she had a henna tattoo on
her belly right I mean that's a lot for
you know inside-the-beltway lawyer right
right no it was it was but you know this
yeah it today I'm still your lifestyle
is so much different than ours
but we were talking last night we just
you know loved it we think it's so great
and we love the kids Julius is an
amazing but I mean you know just
continues to astound me with her stuff
that she does and she comes up with and
now last night Nancy said the nicest
things to Jaya after after Mathis had
left she she just Nancy's is just
enamored with with giant and what a free
spirit she is so
she's a cool kid yeah you have a long
way we've you know we've made some you
know choices about how to live that our
you know a little bit different and you
know that comes with you know we're not
always making the right decisions about
that but you know I feel like we're
trying to you know live in an authentic
way and and do it you know as
responsible Nancy always says how does
he make any money and I constantly
explain it as best I can
by there is somewhat of a mystery well
there's no you know there's no edifice
or boss you know from which the paycheck
comes and it's a different you know it's
look it's I don't get a w-2 no well well
maybe do I don't know no I don't get
that W to what we can I can explain all
of that to me later but she did say it
was funny she's like chief pay the
guests to come on the ship on the
podcast I'm hoping to get me I'll send
you the check later yeah so and I try I
try to be you know empathetic and
sympathetic to that because it is so
different but I think we're we're in a
good place now rme yeah I think so I
think so yeah well I feel like we you
and I have grown a lot closer over the
last you know two years or something
like that and that that's warms my heart
and I would like to you know continue
that evolution well thank you you know
all right
you know I'm reserved about stuff like
that but yeah I
what do you mean reserved well I'm have
more trouble talking about our
relationship you know how much I love
you and things like that so that's just
just we don't have to do it it's just
the way I miss away it's the way I am
well let's talk about let's talk about
George Marshall oh my god are you ever
gonna get to it a book this is why I'm
here I know well first of all you know
it's your third book and you know
tackling something like this you know
it's such a huge commitment of
and resources and energy like how do you
settle on your subject matter like why
did you decide like George Marshall is
the person I want to spend the next five
years with yeah it's sorry it's a
progression because of the the all three
books I actually have a common person
that runs through them and and it's the
founder of my law firm step down john
serese the first book was about Louie
Johnson who was Secretary of Defense
under Truman fired by Truman famously
and replaced by George Marshall so yeah
there's a through law that through line
and then Harry Hopkins the second book
was you know Roosevelt's one of
Roosevelt's closest advisors and lived
in a white house for three and a half
years and was a you know former social
worker but he and he and Marshall of all
people became really close close friends
and that Marshall used Hopkins to get to
Roosevelt or he was a you know a form of
communication to the White House because
George Marshall did not want to get real
close on a social or intimate
relationship with Franklin Roosevelt it
was it was a moral code that he had so I
you know I almost abandoned the Marshall
project because my first agent and
publisher you know did not like my
original proposal actually it was a much
shorter treatment of Marshall but they
you know they didn't I don't think my
agent really got it and she didn't
really know you know sort of that era
that time that timeframe so I switched
agents and you know they encouraged me
to make it a big book and they
encouraged me you know I said you've got
you know you've got talent as a writer
and you know you can do this so they
that's why it got to be as big as you
know as long ago because it's possible
also where there was like this treasure
trove of documents that were recently
discovered right yeah a lot of stuff
the question is you know there's been
biographies about Marshall there's a
four-volume you know 2,000 page
biography that was sort of the you know
the the standard thing back in the 80s
by a guy named Forrest Pogue so
everything you know you have to start
with that but all that you know all the
letters the family letters and so on
were donated to the Marshall Foundation
a you know three or four years ago and
then we happened to meet with George
Marshalls would be his step grace step
grandson Marcia had no children and he
had this favorite stepson named Alan
brown who was killed in the war World
War two that's a hole right and that's a
big story part of my book but his his
that the guy that was killed his son
lives up in northern Massachusetts and
he you know we went up Nancy and I went
up to visit with he and his wife in this
little farmhouse it's up on the border
between Vermont and Massachusetts on the
Connecticut River and he pulls out this
box of documents underneath a you know a
banshan is in his dan you know started
pulling things out and you know and that
just went nuts you know yeah
letters that had you know in these thean
envelopes that were written during the
war that the so called V letters back
and forth
so he loaned that that whole box to me
so I you know took him home and I
actually started getting nervous that
I'd lose them or something like that so
I I made records of all of them and gave
them back but for example you know the
the battle the battle map that was in
this guy's father's hand when he was
leading a tank on the way to Rome shot
in the head with a sniper but the battle
map itself just gave me a chills because
I had a piece of a piece of Mars history
uh so the thing about Marshall though is
character and if I if you have to say
anything about the book it's just you
say what it's about what is it about you
know what is it it's it's character yeah
Lee Lee I mean look we're talking about
a guy who's you know arguably the most
distinguished military leader since
George Washington right and you know a
guy who you know five-star general who
had a career that spanned 50 years under
ten presidents and all these in
different incarnations from great
military leader to you know being
Secretary of Defense and Secretary's day
Secretary of State and you know winning
the Nobel Prize and you know being a
leader in World War one and World War
two and then ultimately all the way
through the Cold War I mean right this
guy's legacy is just you know it's
insane but he's always kind of been
perceived as this austere you know stoic
who nobody could really kind of get a
handle on his his personality or his
character and that's kind of what you've
been able to crack here with this I hope
so
but it's not easy with him he is a very
very difficult character to get a handle
on but with the with the letters from
his you know to and from him he's
favored this the son he never had his
stepson right he married his first wife
couldn't have kids right she had a heart
condition right and died and then he
then he marries this actress later yeah
and you know gets the steps on Allen who
was kind of the son he never had
right and ends up sort of pulling some
strings to make sure that he got into
this Tank Battalion that ultimately lens
leads to his demise right so there's
that ironic thing
yeah Marshall pulled strings he never
would do in a favor for anybody but he
did for this kid headstrong stepson that
he really loved got him into the first
Armored Division which had just finished
with Kasserine pass and was going into
Italy and and of course Marshall from a
strategic point of view would never
wanted to be in Italy anyway had this
fight
Churchill over that so but anyways
stepson they pull strings for gets into
Italy and then gets killed and actually
his wife Catherine the the mother of
Allen knew that she found out that
Marshall had pulled strings to get him
into this armored tank unit and she was
mad oh yeah you know she means that
could be considered an unforgivable and
he brought he wrote Allen uh he said
keep this confidential but your mother
is really angry about how I got you into
this stuff but you know and you know
when he was killed it was you know
obviously a devastating thing for for
his mother and everybody else but so
that story is that sort of a backstory
that goes into talking about Marshall
and all of his accomplishments setbacks
you know mistakes but you know probably
his greatest moment in the moment he'll
be remembered for was a speech at
Harvard in 1947 where he he was not a
great speaker but he gave the the speech
that introduced the Marshall Plan which
what became known as the Marshall Plan
he never called it the Marshall Plan but
it was called the Marshall Plan and it
was the economic plan that the United
States financed that saved Western
Europe right Rehana rebuilding Europe it
was originally they called the Truman
plan right but Truman's popularity was
you know I got her at the time well
Truman said yeah I don't call it that
anything it's anything that they send up
with my name on it is gonna what do you
say anything that they send up to the
hill with my name on it is gonna quiver
a couple of times I fall on to its belly
and die he's right even the worst
congressman even the worst Republican
will vote for something if it has
Marshalls name on it you know so anyway
his name he's quite you know he's called
the man with a plan
but he did so much more so I had this
great reverence for
for the way he conducted himself in the
strong character he had because he could
have been he could have been president
he could have been anything right he
turned down the job of you know leading
well Eisenhower became president because
of Marshall Marshall could have had the
job of leading the Normandy invasion
which it's an it's not only it's the
75th anniversary in June but Marshall
could have had that had he asked for it
and he wouldn't ask for it so president
wanted him in Washington at the line and
he was able to kind of you know set
aside his own personal ambitions and his
ego for you know what was required to do
the job which goes to that you know
issue of character I mean do you think
you know time and time again this is a
guy who's like so disciplined in how he
compartmentalizes his personality in
order to kind of do the job and he's
continually you know you know from from
like building you know the military
complex as we know it today from scratch
and you know reinvigorating the officer
corps like all of these things like the
legacy of the work that he did back then
were still living with but do you think
like had he liked what it what is the
price that he paid for you know
ascribing to this you know ego is the
enemy kind of you know stoic mindset I
mean could he have been president like
what what you know what would has his
path have been had he allowed himself to
probably probably wouldn't have been
that great president because he was so
he had this moral code that would he's
very he's much more inflexible I suppose
with respect to politicians he had a you
know I you just want to play it again a
form of contempt yeah you know the
toward the political side of things and
he he had a terrible temper
which he meant and managed to control
most of the time but sometimes it Lewis
the the people that have blurbed the
book another about ten of them I think
now you know some famous authors and you
know the generals and so on the what you
know what their sum is sum of our saying
at some of its just implicit is that you
know in this they say things like in
this era of failed leadership today you
know this this man George Marshall you
know stands out or wish we had a
Marshall today that kind of stuff so
there's a political you know that I
think the reviews and so forth of the
book are gonna probably be looking at
that and they timeliness of it because
the juxtaposition of his moral character
you know in contrast to what we're
seeing you know currently the a more
like kind of you know hoist him up as
this example you know that or this this
kind of archetype that we need to
reconnect with and probably the person
today that most resembles Marshall in
terms of his behavior and character is
is as general mattis of course resigned
because the president forget exactly
what the president didn't do that he
wanted to do but there were serious so
many things that happened since then
it's down so Matt mattis was kind of a
monk like character he way he wasn't
even married or isn't there never
married but his kind of regard it has
the same sort of person who you know is
above it all but do you think that a
person of you know Marshalls kind of
ethical stature could even survive you
know Capitol Hill right now only not
without you know somebody who's gonna
say I stand on this ground and I'm not
going to play you know I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna submit the histrionics of
daily politics isn't gonna last a week
it's not to say he wasn't I mean in
order to get the Marshall Plan passed
through
it was a titanic job as you're talking
about post-war America we're trying to
get our economy back on their feet and
they want to spend at that time thirteen
billion dollars on saving a bunch of
countries in Western Europe so the
selling of that Marshall Plan was a
hugely political exercise and Marshall
was it because he was regarded as
nonpartisan had a huge role in in
basically lobbying the congressman so it
wasn't like he you know was one of the
reasons why my Roosevelt wanted him in
Washington was because he was good with
Congress hmm so I'm just saying you know
the political situation the his
political expertise it was it was a
different kind now if if he were
Secretary of Defense or Secretary of
State under under Trump I can't imagine
it would last you know for more than six
months right you know he might have let
a few things go by but if he's getting
continually undermined or contradicted
or belittled you know either that or
somehow he would have captured Trump and
as he did Truman Truman just you know
you know revered Marshall I mean
anything you know any Marshall want but
Trump would never do that in my judgment
so I mean what are the what are the kind
of lessons that we can draw from this
guy's example that are relevant you know
helping us kind of understand but
finding our way forward in this climate
I don't you know character matters you
know you know we you know it just and
magnanimity I mean you know David Brooks
wrote a great little book about
character and I just heard him on a
podcast the other day he's had quite a
revelation in his personal life I know I
know
and the recent book and people are
wondering whether he's Christian or
Jewish and all that
as stuffing yeah that's kind of beside
the point I tell well but they are and
so in any event you know character
matters is are we ever going to get back
to the to the point where we have these
kinds of people in our government you
know the last we've been hearing a lot
about the Bush family recently because
of Susan pages book about Barbara Bush
and Susan page is a good friend of ours
and you know the last kind of president
that that bore any resemblance and and
had a cabinet that bore any resemblance
to the way it was with Marshall is
George HW Bush probably so and are we
ever gonna you know are we ever going to
get back to the era where we have moral
people that will take stands on
principle well there's a there seems to
be a split and I'm interested you know
in your perspective on this as somebody
who's lived in Washington for a very
long time and it's steeped in you know
politics as you know a beltway insider
there's there's the perspective that
what's happening now is is an anomaly
that's what we have to weather it out
and you know that ballast we'll find you
know its neutral point you know that it
will swing back towards some semblance
of normalcy right and the other camp
which is things are never going to be
the same and we created a different
system and we've accepted certain things
and created precedents for which you
know it's unclear I'm afraid what the
future holds I'm concerned about that
and and what so what do like your
colleagues you know on Capitol Hill like
what is the you know kind of inside
banter on all of that I you know I think
that the communications that we have now
in getting the information out and how
quickly it gets out you know by tweet
you know and all that all the social
media has changed it probably forever
you know and we're react we have to
you act much quicker to everything
there's and and so you know I do think
that we're never going to get back to
sort of the old days of George HW Bush
and that kind of you know it's a little
it's a leadest it's a you know you know
the branch stroke Scowcroft sand and and
those kinds of people and you know
Cheney and Rumsfeld I think you know in
terms of the cabinet that eight that the
George George W had you know took us
part of that way in terms of you know
not having not having the I don't know
there's the standing the strength of
character that somebody like Marshall or
the predecessors have had so I think I
think there there's probably a permanent
shift that isn't good and we're not
going to come back to it so I'm not the
identity politics the idea that we now
have you know twenty probably more than
twenty I think the de Blasio is gonna
about is about to move into the
Democratic candidate see everybody's
running for president right once it's
unbelievably one-term senators I heard a
joke the other day somebody said like
they could just throw in a name with a
stock photo of somebody to see if they
could just if it would just fly over the
radar tell somebody said wait who's that
guy it's the guy from the Abercrombie &
Fitch catalog yeah and I haven't even
heard about Howard Schultz lately but it
you know I haven't heard anything about
him yes so you know everybody thinks
well if Trump can could pull it off you
know somebody else yes so you know and
I'm worried about what will happen when
Trump loses which you know good chance
he will next time around you know the
transition and you know when he's out of
power he'll be he'll be in
he'll be causing just about as much
trouble as he is now
yeah it's not he's not gonna go quietly
the night no matter what happens no what
is that gonna look terrible transition
and yeah it's so I don't want to be you
know a lot overly you know
sounded like an old grouch about about
you know how things are going these days
and so forth and the good old days you
know there are some great candidates
among the Democrats I'm not sure you
know who I would choose at this point
it's early ladies so you know but when
you when you look at you know back to
Marshall look when you look at his
character and his you know incredible
capacity for leadership like what are
what are some of those leadership skills
that we can extract from his example
that you'd like to see more of like if
if somebody's listening to this and
they're running a small company or
they're a coach or a teacher like what
are these you know I'm interested in
kind of like how you distill down write
what it was about him that made him so
effective well I think the you know his
his choice of people to be put in
various jobs you know he didn't like
self-promoters he didn't you know he he
was selfless himself to a enormous
degree and you know so he chose people
that weren't self-promoters chose people
that that well that that that replicated
his own his own abilities terms of
leading leading people a lot of it has
to do with I think Dean Acheson used to
try to describe it
Dean Acheson worked with with Marshall a
lot Dean Acheson with Secretary of
Defense or Secretary of State after
Marshall he had a sense when he entered
the room
there was a everybody and know that he
was entering the room right yeah it was
a sense of controlled power now what was
that it was you know he he didn't he ran
meetings where he basically let
everybody talk before he he he would
then render an opinion he had this
amazing gravitas you know and people
didn't mess around with him
how did he do that the best the best
words that I could remember from war
Acheson swords controlled power he was
under control
everything was businesslike rapid-fire
it was all serious stuff no joking
around no you know [ __ ] and or if
there was [ __ ] he would call it out
but he always he let everybody else talk
hmm you know until they were done and
then he would say okay this is what
we're gonna do right he was not you know
he was not a good speaker public speaker
notorious read read speeches he was more
effective in in small groups I think I
think he everybody knew he lived by a
moral code that was above most others
and they did not want to you know they
did not want to displease him in any way
you know he said you know he used to say
to the guys that work for him women
actually he was a fairly an important
promoter of women later in the end when
he was Secretary of State but he would
he would say you know don't don't you
know don't worry the problem don't worry
you know I I don't want to hear about
how you you know the trouble you're
having with my with my assignments solve
the photo just to it yeah yeah you know
I I don't want to hear about that stuff
I hit you know when he when he when he
when he was trying to figure out how to
decide design the Marshall Plan he
didn't design it
he found the guide the brightest guy you
know in the State Department George
Kennan and he pulled can enough from the
War College or wherever he was and said
and brought him into Washington's right
after it became Secretary of State he
set up a policy planning thing anyway he
explained his vision of a Marshall Plan
to help Western Europe and he said to
Cannon you got three weeks to come up
with a plan and Kennedy said well you
know what do you want now you have any
guidance or whatever sit yeah avoid
trivia and now he may have said a few
more things than that but cannon cannon
already knew that
in fact cannon what cannon wrote back in
1946 about Russia is so so far if such a
a perfect analysis of the way the
Russian you know people and their
governments are and have been ever since
either they're doing the same thing
today that cannon talked about back in
1946 and so respects Marshall phone
well that that they were paranoid there
was a paranoid not just you know it's
not just Stalin Stalin at the time but
now we're dealing with Putin and all the
people since between them borders it's
all about border security and when NATO
is expanding now from it used to be 12
countries 229 surrounding surrounding
the Soviet Union
well now today Russia you know right on
their borders you know it drives them
crazy and and you can make an argument
that we should never have expanded NATO
the way we have because it just
exacerbates the problems that we have
with Russia but also their desire to
destabilize this is back in 1946 he was
talking about that now today we're using
you know cyber cyber Malthus to to
stabilize the United States
but Kenan was predicting it back then
but Canada was such an intellectual as
always hard to ever pin him down because
the in a minute you started talking well
it's all about you know we got to have
more missiles or what no I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about containing
them through through economics so I'm
just saying Marshall
picked Kenan put him in the first thing
he did when he came to the States farm
he said nobody around here is thinking
about you know problems that we may face
in the future we need he got candy
brought Kenan back from Russia or from
wherever he was I think it was at Russia
at the time and set up a policy planning
thing and cannon basically ran the State
Department you know foreign policy under
Marshall so but he crafted the essence
of what became the Marshall Plan yeah
and I think wow there's three different
people actually it was Marshalls
thoughts a guy named chip Boland
actually wrote the first draft of the
speech he was a young interpreter but a
very smart guy and then cannon cannon
was the big brain but what I hear and
that is in Marshall this guy who would
you know approach these problems by
finding the smartest people who knew
more than him and he wasn't afraid to
push them out front and to sublimate his
own personal aspirations or echoic
tendencies in order to get the job and
you say that better than I do that's
right yeah and the lesson in that is you
know ultimately you know at the end of
the day like this guy's one of the
greatest statesmen of all time and we
all know who he is and yet that was
forged through you know a persistent
refusal to you know make these decisions
based on his own personal advancement
like the iron Joe that you know what I
mean and I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of there's a lot to be
appreciated about that set you know that
that that level of selfless you mail it
I mean this is what Ryan talks about in
this book
you know it's ego is the enemy like if
when you're when you're being driven by
your ego versus sublimating the ego for
Menino sublimating the ego in order to
be of maximum service to getting the job
done properly without forethought for
who's getting credit for it ultimately
results in the advancement that you're
probably seeking anyway it's right and
it happened to Marshall and too you know
iconic moments one when he grabbed
General Pershing in first world war
grabbed him by the arm
because Pershing had common and and it
had criticized the training of the first
division when they were this is when
they were still trying to get ready to
go into into the first world war they
were over in France training Pershing
came and ripped everybody apart and
Marshall was at that time a major in not
a general he was you know and grabbed
Pershing's arm literally it was like you
know grab that you know that you know
the head of the army and the whole that
whole deal American Expeditionary Force
was purging grabbed his arm and said you
don't understand what's going on here
yeah we're getting [ __ ] orders you
didn't say that but he said we're
getting these orders from your people
and back where they are and they don't
make any sense and he went blah blah
blah and it went on and he yeah
everybody said you're done you know yeah
and Persian came back you know a few
days later and said let's sit down and
talk about this I think it yeah same
thing happened with uh with you know 22
years later he's in a meeting where he
want he wants to be appointed by
Roosevelt chief of staff he's up for
being chief of staff but he's sitting in
this meeting in the back of the white
you know Cabinet Room in the White House
and Roosevelt's you know talking away
and you know doing his usual and and
coming up with a plan this is in 1938
you know how many planes they should
build or whatever and he says what don't
you think so George
trying to get everybody else in the room
had agreed on board with his everybody
else in the room had agreed and so yeah
that's right mr. president I know and
Marshall said first of all he's
irritated that he that the president
called him by his first name but
Marshall didn't like that if you didn't
know him if you knew him it was okay
Patton called by first name but so he
said I you know I don't agree with that
at all mr. president hmm and and Rose
over was shy he'd be startled you know
and the meeting ended and it's Oliver uh
Marshalls friends said she's right it's
like you just ruined your chance to be
but there's multiple examples of this
where he speaks in truth to power in a
very blunt and frank way in a in a
career-ending way and yet ultimately he
keeps sort of I'm not just surviving
that but advancing himself is now you
know if he if if you know he did that to
Trump you know Trump would you ever
confront him personally but it but you
know it might be the end of him with
drop I don't know what was what was the
the most surprising thing that you
learned about him and all of this
research that you've done over the years
well I saw I suppose that you know the
inner life part of it it was you know
there he's actually a human being
yeah and around his yet a few intimate
friends you know and I relate to that
you know not he wasn't you know he
didn't like to go out and in Washington
and you know socialized and all that
stuff but he you know he had this
intense love I you know one of things I
didn't even put in the book was they
sent Alan the favorite step stone to a
prep school in Virginia called Woodberry
forest and on one of my trips down to
Lexington I decided I'm gonna go to
Woodberry forest the prep school and see
what they have in terms of letters from
Marshall or Marshalls life to this kid
while he was in prep school
kid was always getting in trouble he was
yeah I knew he was you know and but he
was a great athlete and that's what
marshals loved you know to go fishing
with him and you know you know monitor
his progress at Woodberry forest so I
couldn't believe it the prep school let
me look at everything there was there
and I didn't find anything you know I
found out about how he stole a car one
night and you know escaped and almost
got kicked out of school and then the
letters that go back and forth and how
he and the various exploits but and how
Marshall and his wife reacted to that so
you know here they're just parents you
know they're just like everybody else
yes not with his pants on one leg like
everyone else yeah he and he and they
they had this relationship with a young
girl Rose who they met when uh when he
and his first wife moved into Washington
they moved in this apartment building
and Rose was only eight and she was
precocious and she started she saw
Marshall in his uniform and started
talking to man the elevator and and he
just you know he established a
relationship that went for the rest of
his life with her she had she was his
goddaughter she and all this stuff
and she wrote actually wrote a book
about it so so you can find out and you
know how he confessed to her when he
lost his first wife you know so there
was it a whole human side right like
this more robust interior life that yeah
I would have imagined so and this book
is really kind of the first place better
yeah where you're I think so yeah but
you know I don't you don't want to get
there's so much in terms of his
accomplishments that you want to also so
you got to figure out the balance
balancing that of you know what he's
doing in the Huayra plan versus you know
and then there was a year in China which
you know it defies you know description
where he's
supposed to negotiate a coalition
government between the Communists and
the Nationalists right like between
Chiang kai-shek and so you know it's so
and how hard he tried and how that
ultimate hopeless failure terrible
failure terrible failure buddy you know
and he spent too much time trying to do
it but again and that was where he
wouldn't take no for an answer
everybody said you're never gonna be
able to do this of course they were
right but yeah so he made it he made
some he made a big mistake in terms of
civil military relations he almost
crossed the line with Roosevelt and you
know he had all this reasons but he he
engaged in a sort of resistance to
civilian Authority for maybe three or
four weeks when he you know you know
because he stand he you know he stands
as an example of you know he observes
that the distinction between civilian
Authority and military authority but he
violated that right that code but he
came back from it what do you think I
mean
Truman sort of famously sounded this
warning bell about the the impending
problematic nature of the growing
military industrial complex well that
was really Eisenhower's but oh right it
was eisenhower sad that was his famous
speech right yeah that famous speech
what do you think Marshall would think
of what that has become today well I
think he'd probably have some of the
same reactions that Eisenhower had but
the one thing that he that that he began
promoting and it's why Stanley
McChrystal likes this book is so much
about Marshall he believed that as a
result of what happened in the
depression in the depression one of
Roosevelt's brainchild was creating the
civil Civilian Conservation Corps
where they took all these young at that
point it was all men young men 18 years
old who were whose parents you know
didn't have job 25% unemployment so he
took all these young men and moved him
into camps around the country and the
army ran it it's like a New Deal thing
oh yeah this is the New Deal 1932
actually not by the summer of 1933 this
plan was put together and they were
moving them all over the country putting
him in tents and they were chopping
trees down and they were planning bushes
and parks and they were building dams
and they were doing all kinds of stuff
well Marshall was involved in that
during the Depression he first of all he
ran the Southeast Division and then he
did but he loved the idea of how these
men from all walks of life would come
together and you know it was a unifying
thing and it was also about being a
citizen so he took that concept from the
depression and he started promoting it
and he actually got a lot of traction
right after the Second World War with a
bill universal military service you know
as a way to avoid a large standing army
and of course you know we have the
voluntary army today but in other words
instead of having to draft these people
from scratch if you ever get into a
conflict you'd have a everybody that it
would be like Israel you would have two
or three you're kind of ready to go now
that doesn't you know in today's world
it might be more national service and
that's what Stanley McChrystal is
promoting today not getting anywhere
with it very far but the idea of having
citizens you know that learns about
citizenship by helping by doing
something helping something getting paid
by the government maybe which is would
be hugely expensive but he always he
always loved the idea of national
service and he had great great respect
for
how you know if you get everybody
together in some project you know when
they're young they come out of it and we
have a more informed citizenship and an
esprit de corps and a sense of community
and purpose and right now there's a lot
that comes out of it so you know and the
guy from Brooklyn and and the you know
the in the Native American from Arizona
and you know the you know all that sort
of thing melding together with a
citizenship it may be you know two
altruistic and two but but it was
something that was ingrained in him and
it was that's quite that's quite a you
know quite far afield from you know the
current reality in which we have this
intersection between you know the the
defense contractors and you know the K
Street lobbyists oh and the legislators
that are you know really for lack of a
better word this cabal that you know
creates policy at the highest level that
drives our foreign policy right and that
was what you know kind of the crux of my
question like like what would Marshall
think of that like that's very different
from the esprit de corps of some kind of
national service right where you know
the amount of money and influence that
gets peddled into decisions around how
we're ramping up our military and our
spending and how that trickles down and
do decisions that we make overseas is
you know it's it's disturbing and and
yeah it of course has it it's driven by
you know having projects in the
congressman's local districts right and
it's a jobs program you know rather than
what do we really need for national
defense right and trying to shut down
any of these programs is impossible
right and that's troubling yes it is and
I'm sure what troubled Marshall there's
no question about you know he he was so
far removed from you know the I you know
he used to do budgets and all kinds of
things like that but you know
ever had a he never went out and you
know had to have sort of a regular a
regular job his wife you know bought the
his wife had money a second wife or the
second wife yeah she came from a family
of of you know Baker Beckett and Civil
War they made money in the south but
cheap fine as she bought the houses
right now she bought a house well
there's that that famous house that did
own a house in Rea Leesburg
she that was her you know she bought
that and I don't you know Marshall was
offered tons of money to write his
memoirs said another thing about him you
know everybody writes a book today right
but he he had all kinds of people after
him all the time to write a book memoir
could have made you know and untold
amounts of money and most of these
generals are doing it it'll be
interesting to see what he had a rich
wife and he was living in a really nice
house yeah so he didn't need the money I
don't you know I don't think they they
ever lacked the other although they they
had a my you know if ma she bought the
house in Leesburg and then they bought
this one-story house part of the way
down south in North Carolina where where
he spent a lot of the later years but
you know they did you know he was
getting a salary from the army until he
he you know until he died Wow
so but he famously did not he said I if
I you know if I wrote my memoirs I'd
have to you know talk about some people
that I'd rather not talk about or some
missions I won't I want I don't want to
disparage in yeah if you had a wonderful
befitting of a man of that you know kind
of moral attitude but you know he he was
he was friends with George Patton and
Patton really you know when after
Marshall to be close to him and and but
you know he understood Patton you know
patent you know understood patent needed
to be
he was the combat general that you know
everybody had to him so when Eisenhower
was was trying to decide whether they
get rid of Patton because of the
slapping incidents that got in all the
newspapers are so said no we got to use
them will use them will use them after
we after we get into Normandy as soon as
we get in a Normandy we're gonna put him
back in so they used him as a decoy
before Normandy so he understood people
like that but yeah he didn't you know he
didn't he wasn't he didn't respect
patent for his well his peccadilloes
well yeah and his self-promotion so
which was highly effective yeah and yeah
pad yeah Patton once had an opportunity
when Marshall needed a place to live
you know Patton took him into one of his
apartments or one of his houses that he
wrote his wife's boy have I pulled off a
big one I'm gonna get a lot of you know
I'm now close to Marshall and uh-huh and
he said and then he says to his wife but
I'm not getting out much anymore
so anyway it's yeah well good let's wrap
this up yeah going for two hours um it
is an amazing accomplishment I'm super
proud of you it's gonna take me a while
like I said to work my way through it
but I am looking forward to it don't
worry about it no I'm I'm gonna I'm more
enthusiastic now about reading it and
I'm just delighted that you accomplished
this I mean it's no small thing and I'm
super excited for everybody to having it
have a chance to read it so it comes out
July 9th July 9th
um yeah I'm we're hoping to have an
event up in the at the chief of staff's
house in late June I'm not sure that's
going to work yet but where we kind of
launched it I'll have some books
available by then
but I like to go and you know talk about
it various places yes so I'll do that no
you'll be doing the book tour and I'll
put on my website and on the episode
page in the show notes not only links to
buy the book but any appearances that
you're doing I'm having to share with
everybody I love you I love you too
very much super proud of you and this
was really fun so thing right and tell
Ryan hi
oh well okay it's up Ryan good and this
is the point where I say and you can you
can follow Dave on Twitter yes that
stuff so yeah I guess you can hit me up
yeah get to him but thank you thank you
alright let's go see the kids all right
all right peace
[Music]